depuis 2014 les écarts grandissent au
ministère des finances à québec entre
des prévisions budgétaires et les
résultats un an plus tard on en parle ce
soit avec l'économiste jean-pierre aubry
à ta voix puis aubry bonsoir bonsoir
d'abord comment ça marche à chaque
budget les fonctionnaires se réunissent
du ministère des finances font des
projections sur l'érosion des tensions
sur l'économie et les revenus qu'ils
pensent obtenir ensuite de ça ils vont
prendre des provisions provenant des
ministères pour savoir combien de
dépense et on mélange touche ensemble et
on en vient à des décisions
est-ce qu'on veut changer les revenus ou
est ce qu'on veut des nouveaux
programmes de dépenses et on présente un
budget où on à la colonne des revenus la
colonne des dépenses et le solde
budgétaire qu'on prévoit réaliser durant
cet exercice là en principe donc ce sont
des prévisions à moins d'une catastrophe
ou d'un cataclysme ça doit se passer à
peu près mais ça se passe pas toujours
exactement comme on l'avait prévu
ce sens il ya toujours des surprises des
surprises positives qui fait qu'elle
seule peut augmenter ou colossal plus
diminué mouais cela dit à québec depuis
quelques années puis on a préparé un
tableau qu'on va voir tout de suite que
vous avez préparé avec nous il ya de
grands écarts entre qu'on prévoit est ce
qui se passe dans la réalité en 2014
2015 écart d'un milliard deux cents
millions entre la projection une
résultats l'année d'après 2 milliards
200 millions les deux années suivantes 2
milliards 6,2 milliards 6,4 milliards
400 millions des 40 18 19 13 milliards
d'écart entre ce qu'on prévoit est ce
qui s'est passé comment ça s'explique
une des grandes raisons de cet écart là
c'est relié dans les trois dernières
années notamment au fait que l'économie
a été plus performant ce qu'on le
pensait on a été surpris même son tir
ajusté de budget un budget pour dire oui
oui l'économie plus élevé
et on va avoir plus de show on est
toujours ce prix presque d'année en
année on n'a pas fait des ajustements
suffisants et aussi on n'a pas dépensé
complètement les sommes qu'on avait pour
les budgets des dépenses de mission du
gouvernement
donc les revenus sont plus élevés parce
que l'économie va mieux puis on dépense
moins est ce qu'un problème de calcul ou
est-ce qu'on sous estime volontairement
les revenus et on surestime
volontairement les dépenses je dirais
d'abord au niveau des revenus le
gouvernement fait un effort très louable
pour se rapprocher des projections de
différentes entreprises de projection
dans la structure d'un secteur financier
et quand on regarde ces dernières années
les prévisions du ministère des finances
n'ont pas été beaucoup plus faible que
celle des gens du marché il ya eu
véritablement une surprise non seulement
pour le gouvernement mais aussi pour les
prix visionnaire du secteur privé de
sacs qu'on a eu un peu plus au niveau
des dépenses on a vraiment une culture
surtout depuis 2014 pour faire attention
pour ne pas tout dépensé de manquer de
ressources en fin d'année et il ya aussi
un espèce de culture qui consiste à dire
on ne veut pas de déficit
et si jamais on a des surplus
additionnel bien c'est merveilleux on va
pouvoir réduire la dette plus rapidement
ce soit qui ait un billet lors qui fait
que le gouvernement de par la structure
de décision cherche vraiment à des
assurons nous qu'on n'a pas difficile ou
à mieux sont faits des surplus mais on
en vient presque une culture de surplus
on parle tellement on va plus loin que
l'équilibré budgétaire on est même dans
une culture de surplus budgétaires est
ce que c'est une bonne chose dans le
fond la question c'est une bonne chose
si tu veux dire aux marchés
regardez on est tellement plus d'un
conte a fait plus et on réduit la dette
donne une bonne track pour notre dette
est dans ce sens là c'est une bonne
chose pour le gouvernement par contre le
gouvernement
à dire aux citoyens voici ce que je vais
dépenser pour mes dépenses de mission la
santé d'éducation et quand arrive que tu
vois qu'ils ont pas tout dépensé et
qu'il ya des services qui ont pas été
rendus qui ont des problèmes l'autre dit
qu'est ce qui se passe on ne pas
utiliser tout notre budget alors qu'il y
avait des besoins
ouais et alors qu'une perte de
crédibilité sur la capacité de dire
combien on veut passer et ça ça se passe
même si le gouvernement faire la fin
d'année fait des dépenses additionnelles
pour réduire cet écart là malgré ça on a
des surplus additionnel d'année en année
et ce qui est troublant c'est qu'à
chaque année ils situent tous le même
signe c'est des surplus
si on avait tant attend un déficit qu'on
dirait au total c'est pas trop loin de
zéro pas de problème non
on a déçu ce pru presque systématique
donc un problème de transparence
d'une certaine façon oui le gouvernement
doit être plus clair et d'une certaine
façon il doit se rapprocher de ce qui
nous dit dans ses budgets notamment au
niveau de ses dépenses mais aussi
d'expliquer les écarts entre les
demandes pour les services et lov qu'il
fait pour les services
et voici un écart grandissant par
exemple lentement au niveau de la santé
une des choses qu'on entend beaucoup
c'est oui le gouvernement augmente ses
dépenses en santé mais la demande ne
recommande plus oui on a besoin d'une
information plus exact bien dans les
saunas message clair merci beaucoup jean
pierre aubry
merci